[Music]
and I'm me but not me news oh I know
what that was a mean submitted by
where's the remote right here
a man's DNA was replaced by that of a
donor following a bone marrow trial
wait so they found that man's DNA's been
in a woman's DNA no no stupid his DNA
was replayed do you answer every
question he asked I got that I have to
make sure I end up with the hard [ __ ]
stupid Bart's talking about they found
out a long time ago all right
are you eating no you're not supposed to
eat when we filmed a mouthful of nuts
for the joke
it was for the bit yeah he has a mouth
full of nuts low sodium good good okay
this story is about Chris Chris Chris
works at the Washoe County Sheriff's
Department
in Nevada he works in ITIN the IT
department why do we have to know these
details about his life come on I was
like they're gonna find this man okay
thank you
yeah okay I had the same problem earlier
cuz we related because eating Starbucks
okay sorry
Chris was suffering from a cute myeloid
leukemia oh my oh it's fasting my little
cute syndrome and so he needed a
bone-marrow transplant
oh [ __ ] luckily his doctor found a donor
who was a German man that he had never
met who was like 10 years younger too
and they only spoke to each other via
messages a couple of times before the
actual transplant and then so mmm
I heard that your bone marrow transplant
guy's gonna be screaming his brains out
me he likes pain the soonest donates
marrow you know you have to like really
like the cause or really like pain art
your cousin I know
to save her brother but like my dad did
it to save his sister but to just donate
bone marrow either you lost somebody
that could have been saved with bone
marrow ask you some why would you save a
stranger [ __ ] that because if you lost
someone that they could have been saved
like that was close to you I stand
corrected and you're like oh maybe I
could save someone else
sit back down would you save a stranger
if they were a male and alia no I
wouldn't save a stranger something
happened to me like where like I lost
you but you could have been saved with
bone marrow so then I'm like maybe I
could save him through and save his
honor you know it was if it was the
Train versus the key you know that that
that philosophical question like the
[ __ ] train pull the people or you
could Steve or Mike it yeah [ __ ] though
train you would not pull me up from
train tracks kid I would I would be like
leave me I would save you over the train
any day if you could you couldn't call
strangers if you're gonna die why you
didn't save your life
no she couldn't pick me up you're
thinking of a different train thing you
press a button for this train 100 that's
it so the trainer hits you or it's your
time like that you by are busy she could
be very busy she's gonna take the time
we all have different train scenarios
and I think I'll all right destroy the
whole city and the Train for someone I
love same this each is beauty so the
train doesn't ever go in to the tunnel
you don't I like to think about
sometimes is speaking of destroying
cities example is how the in old
Godzilla movies there's a guy in the
costume so really he's just a guy in a
costume Gorelick and then there's a
director taking it seriously like hey
hey hey can you smash that again and
it's a Japanese guy yeah well pretty
please to do that again
anyway back to Chris so when he ended up
right before he had his surgery his work
colleagues because remember he works at
the Sheriff's Department in Nevada
yes his apartment yep yeah we're gonna
find this here
so the his work colleagues that work in
the IT department GI Department lost and
found
why was IT relevant F she's gonna tell
you the department that deals with DNA
the hospitality I couldn't remember I'm
sorry I was just trying to remember t
eyes saying the whole time what the
thing I don't know doesn't he was saying
it Busey a still a very good [ __ ]
checked if she's a virgin that's that's
the same Jim Oh anyway you nice to the
forensic Department
I wasn't his no his missus [ __ ] the
police right well that's in the cop show
he's in do you tell me Ice Cube was Ice
Cube was not an NWA no you the story ice
cubes are in the drink iced tea but not
Italy what about vanilla ice yeah wasn't
he in NWA oh come on he was the biggest
NWA science forensic scientists work
colleagues so there was someone there
and they were like oh my god you need to
let me swab your DNA to see with the
changes in your blood [ __ ] key yeah -
can you cover this cup I need to know
part of it oh yeah once your DNA samples
save your life
no it he has an experiment because for
critic Ute though it is he's passionate
think about it let me let me paint
chris's experience thank you Chris
just found out that he has his insane
cancer he doesn't know if he's gonna
even survive yeah
kids you know like he thinks he's been
about to die but then luckily he finds
his bone marrow on my net so then right
before going to the surgery his coworker
comes in and says oh my god my god this
is such a cool experiment so for for
Chris he was like oh this is cool a
distraction let's do a like little
little experiment this distracts me from
like the more teeth let's use the tax
dollars for this guy's amusement park I
was actually a girl so uh part of our
movement so then the scientist was a guy
though we ended up doing that he got
like hair samples semen samples like
swabs in like all birds body that's all
kinds of sample and then with within I
think it was three months got to do like
the bird hey book I broken and then so
like within a few months they found like
his level like his DNA levels so like
his DNA was lowering and the donors DNA
was raising coming here so he actually
has like a hundred percent uh he he's a
chimera he's he has two sets of DNA in
his body human animal hybrid so that
means that he has two sets of DNA so he
ends up only his chest and his head hair
were not affected by the DNA change his
entire semen it is a 100 percent the
donors like he's gonna [ __ ] yell at
his wife of cheating on him so here's
the thing this is what doctors are
saying they're saying that the fact that
Chris had a vasectomy after his second
kid that is the reason why a hundred
percent of the DNA got taken over by the
dog because they're saying like they're
just you know it's literally impossible
for people to make other people's kids
okay yeah well he can commit sex crimes
and blaming on the other guy but that's
the reason why this entire thing is so
fascinating to the forensic Department
because no other department doesn't
matter that you like what they care that
you have two DNA's it's only the
forensic Department because people if
someone
get bone marrow transplant and then they
go on to commit it to a crime you could
frame somebody yeah because you know the
authorities think that everyone's just
leaving one yeah yeah it's like Nicolas
Cage when he burns off his finger
plastering my face off okay so this is
wash you gonna share these secrets huh
thank you watch your county department
Frances Department
what are you talking about like they get
like give the actual details like how to
do it they're telling the story details
this is Chris not the German man along
[Laughter]
the look on that photo right now is I
got another man's coming my body
damn you guess his last name Chris long
it's been four years since his surgery
I'm glad he's alive yeah exactly that's
the thing words they're like man I'm
just happy I'm alive because he really
thought he was gonna die but this has
been an interesting case study because
there have never been another case where
bone marrow recipients do a DNA analysis
before their surgery and after so he
could compare he's the first one to
actually do this cuz most people are on
the verge of death neither got time to
[ __ ] around like that thank God for the
geeky passionate that's still nerd
though
imagine discovering something like
that's never been discovered before
that's so cool that is cool dirty here's
the thing about people being chimeras in
the past time arrows yeah chimera I want
to be a chemist oh so back in 2004
investigate investigators in Alaska
uploaded a DNA profile extracted from
semen to a criminal DNA's database okay
follow me demon yeah the Interpol this
ended up matching a potential suspect
but it turned out that that man was in
prison during the time of the assault so
then later they found out that he had
received a bone marrow transplant and
the donor was his brother who was
convicted for and then another one was
in 2005
oh no no another one was the police
investigators were skeptical of this
sexual assault victims account because
she said there had only been one
attacker but DNA analysis showed that
there were two and then later they found
out that the second profile came from
her bone marrow donor she had two DNA's
and then another one was in they thought
that they shared like a whole shady
story yeah that she was lying or
something yeah and then in 2008 in South
Korea they were there was a traffic
accident they were trying to identify
the victim but his blood showed out to
be that he was a female and so you they
were like what the hell like clearly
this dude's in male sexual but then they
confirmed DNA was he could've been a
mystery yeah but then they confirm the
fact that he was a male through DNA in a
kidney but not in the spleen or the lung
which contained male and female DNA and
then eventually they figured out that
the victim had received a bone marrow
transplant from his daughter this is
like not super common but at least like
this [ __ ] I want you if you start to
pick up traits are you lounging in an
office chair look like it's a chaise
lounge we're having a great conversation
the grand
I wonder if you start to have the person
now know he says that hit like free for
Chris he has the same personality the
theme that we know of
yeah maybe he only remembers memories of
the other guy I know but maybe he's got
it's guilty pleasure maybe he loves
Arby's now yeah and he's like I've
always loved Arby's crazy addiction to
bratwurst in a year impressive so my
cousin they were brother-sister so this
so my cousin must have female DNA too
and he or maybe and then my dad and his
sister were like there's two different
genders and like for those of you don't
understand why the DNA change it's like
what's the bone marrow think so bone
marrow creates blood cells and like
that's obviously where people get DNA
samples like through your blood and
that's the reason why the whole DNA
mix-up happens do you think also tastes
really [ __ ] good oh yeah
so if you're a girl and you got a bone
marrow transferred from a guy can you
develop semen when you come can you
questions everyone's thinking because
when I orgasm nothing comes out I just
it's like it's very anticlimactic it's
like I don't get it like you about that
at all everyone's thinking about it I'm
just asking the tough questions that are
on everyone's mind I don't need you to
come hmm I don't need you stupid
[Music]